Martin en Guyane un report de voie
inattendu a créé la surprise le
président sortant du Parti socialiste
guyanais Antoine Karam reste en place il
était donné perdant face à une liste de
fusions divers gauche qui n'a pas séduit
tous les
militants Antoine Karam peut savourer sa
victoire d'autant qu'elle n'était pas
évidente avec 22% des suffrages exprimés
au premier tour le Parti socialiste
guyanais devait à priori perdre la
présidence il semble que la liste PSG I
du report des voies des indépendantistes
je vous demande d'avoir à mon image le
triomphe
modeste respecter nos adversaires car
nous sommes appelés à travailler pour la
guyade Léon Bertran connaît le même
phénomène que les autres ministres
candidats il est battu et de très peu
oui c'est la défaite nous nous inclinons
devant le verdict des urnes mais nous
continuerons au sein du conseil régional
à à nous opposer à à faire valoir nos
idées c'est logiquement la liste de
fusion conduite par le sénateur George
Tilly qui aurait dû arriver en tête les
électeurs n' semblent-ils pas compris le
retrait personnel de l'autre tête de
liste Christian tobira George Tilly
reste optimiste pour l'avenir il y a
bien sûr eu un éparpillement sinon un
effiettement de des voix qui que nous
avions eu mais cela me donne vraiment du
du du goût à continuer ce combat
la Guyane comme la métropole a largement
augmenté sa participation à ce deuxème
tour elle a progressé de 8 points entre
les deux tours avec un tau de plus de 58
%